just let her finish it up so I am a
grandmother I have three grandchildren I
have never heard of woodcut you turn the
cup over and you have dice in there and
you pull it back
not even close oh no I have heard
something about like juggling Colleges
rubber ones juggler get choked up
regular I may look very sweet and nice
but watch out are you gonna lose but you
know that's life
somebody has to win but I always win so
this is our flip Cup is played we open
our beer and we pour about a quarter of
the cup full drink our beer liner cup up
and try and flip it on to the opposite
so you expect us to do that once that
lens the next person in line goes
trash-talking is essential the more
they're thinking about why they suck the
worse their flip is gonna be exactly you
nailed it willow if and when you win
because you're gonna win
make sure you celebrate for a long time
all right bringing a team of people who
have never played flip cup before so I
need you to crush them all right I know
we can do it grandmas on three bring it
in all right on three one two three
ready
are you ready yeah in your face
there's a lot of fun and I'm drunk from
it because I drank about four things of
beer also it's fun it was expected I was
ready to win
I'm Bharat's time Umbria Garda we good
we good it's good to get older you bring
all your experience and you tap into the
stuff that you've done before and look
at that you beat the young ones well I
wanted to do the cheer because I was a
cheerleader in high school for the bud
scheme give me a B and an e and a D and
an F and the F is the [ __ ] and EE D
BuzzFeed BuzzFeed you're the best
I put that bad word in there though